c'est vous la cgt qui avait fourni des
éléments sur le pôle enquête et dans
cette enquête les mots employés sont
forts à savoir esclavagisme traite
d'êtres humains
benjamin a marre merci d'être là déjà
est-ce que vous pensez que c'était le
moment de sortir ces informations il ya
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui ont dit
c'est pas le moment il aurait dû
attendre un petit peu écoutés en réalité
il faut savoir que la cgt sur cette
affaire depuis un an
d'accord la sphère qui concerne le drame
qui a concerné youri avec cette
agression barbare on meute qui nous a
tous choqués c'est très récent
par contre la faire effectivement qui
concerne la conflit du travail ça c'est
quelque chose d'ancien qu'est ce qui est
reproché à la maman du riz assez des
choses très très grave
c'est des choses très graves et sait pas
c'est pas reprocher par libération par
la cgt c'est l'inspection du travail
d'accord qui effectivement y compris à
diligenter l'office central de lutte
justement que sur le redire sur les sur
les questions de 2,2 de fraude au
travail et avait en lien avec la
préfecture avec la préfecture de police
de paris
derrière on a des questions qui concerne
le travail dissimulé qui concerne alors
le fait d'employer des des salariés qui
ne sont pas en situation irrégulière on
a également les questions de traite des
êtres humains c'est l'infraction la plus
grave sur le code du travail vous
risquez sept ans d'emprisonnement et
150000 euros damende c'est pas une c'est
pas une amende que vous n'avez pas payé
c'est des choses très graves
alors donc nous on a labouré le terrain
avec ses ukrainienne ces travailleuses
ukrainienne depuis un an
voilà il ya une chronologie qui se
télescopent quoi alors la maman du riz
elle affirme que tout est faux j'ai
donné tous les éléments le dernier
rendez-vous de vue sur cette histoire a
eu lieu hier au commissariat du 15e
arrondissement
ce qu'elle dit ce sont des mensonges
j'ai déclaré tout le monde les salariés
racontent n'importe quoi alors alors si
vous permettez vous savez moi je suis
prof d'histoire-géo mais j'ai j'ai
longtemps hésité avec les comment dire
la philosophie et mon philosophe préféré
c'est ce qu'il aura nous c'est ce que
dit spinoza est dit dans le domaine
intellectuel ce qu'il faut faire c'est
agir mort et géométriques au comme un
géomètre et donc faut pas mélanger des
choses qui n'ont rien à voir
sur la question de l'agression qui a
créé beaucoup d'émotion on y comme vous
et les travailleuses ukraine
également elles sont dans l'empathie
c'est cette agression elle a choqué
maintenant il y a autre chose il y à ce
conflit du travail
et moi j'ai été longtemps sur la
question des travailleurs sans papiers
ce dossier il est suivi par ma camarade
marine coup là qui n'est pas disponible
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que moi je
suis là mais on est sur ces dossiers là
depuis des années je ne connais pas un
employeur accusé de choses aussi graves
qui vient et qui vous dit mais oui c'est
ainsi je suis responsable
oui ce sont toujours les travailleurs
qu'ils soient ukrainiens ou maliens qui
ont montré qu'ils ont dissimulé et
derrière il ya l'inspection du travail
il ya une enquête savez elles ont été
reçues par les gendarmes mais en envoyer
une plainte
donc le travail qui va se faire mais moi
je vous dis le dossier je le benêt
marine poulain coller la cgt le connaît
il est lourd il est très lourd